All righty, my guy, this is a crazy bug.
Thanks so much for agreeing to share it.
Thanks for having me.
All right.
I have just because I'm here and I'm talking to you,
I have my water.
I know you're really into that.
Dude, there, here it is right here.
Got my water.
Hydrating.
I've always wanted to drink some water on this podcast.
Dude, dreams, dreams do come true.
Dude, this bug was amazing
and I so appreciate you reaching out, you know,
and saying the kind things about like
how the pod has helped you get there.
And I see you using some of the techniques
we've talked about on the pod.
Absolutely.
So yeah, I guess this is my boy XSS doctor.
Take it away, man.
Tell us about this bug.
So I was, I started to hack on like a kind of a large scope
bounty that, you know, I looked at it for a few days,
three days really, until I found a couple of gadgets.
The first gadget I found on the main site,
it's kind of an e-commerce platform.
And I was looking through the local storage parameters
and I just saw one that it just said was just a JS file,
a remote JS file.
So I just replaced it with my own remote JS file and it popped.
So that's gadget number one.
And not only did it pop, but it popped on every click
of the application.
Wow, dude.
So you were just casually scrolling through the local storage entries?
Yeah.
I was like, I don't know.
Sometimes I like to look at local storage.
I look at window.name.
Like that's like kind of one of the first things I do,
like anything that I could mess with.
So that was like the first thing.
So I'm like, okay, if I could set this local storage parameter,
I have XSS on every click.
And that's pretty big.
So then I was like, looked around for a long time to see if there was a way to arbitrarily
set a local storage parameter.
But there was not.
I feel like that's kind of rare.
I don't know.
Yeah, it's pretty rare.
I mean, like normally you find that the other way around, right?
Like you'll find the way to arbitrarily set a local storage parameter,
and then you'll utilize that to get some exploit.
You don't normally be like, I need to set a local storage parameter
and then like find a magical local storage gadget.
Yeah, every night, that'd be cool.
But hey, man, you moved heaven and earth to make this thing happen.
So I'm not going to put it beyond you.
I went crazy.
Yeah, so then the next thing I was looking around and I found a self XSS on the site.
And that was in when you're creating, you can post stuff, you can post items to sell.
And so when you're posting something to sell in the description section,
if you put brackets or quotes, it would URL encode that.
But if you do it in burp, then or in Kaido, then it will not, it will fire.
But it gives you a warning.
They know about this.
It gives you a warning like, hey, you've put JavaScript in here.
If you post this, it will get taken out.
So it's a self, but you can save the listing for yourself for later.
So every time you click on that listing, the self XSS pops.
So you'd like create a draft and then that draft has a self XSS in it.
But if you were to publish the draft, the XSS would get stripped.
It's and it even like has a thing that says that.
That's hilarious that they allow that still.
I don't understand.
But so that was that.
So I'm like, okay, great.
So I can set the local storage parameter with that XSS, self XSS.
But now all I need is the easiest thing to get in all of hacking, which is a login CSRF.
And so I'm like, I'm done.
I even started like texting my friends about it.
Like, I have this it's done.
Yeah.
And then it turns out that this platform like really, really does not want you to get a login CSRF.
There's like 20 cookies.
Oh, my God.
Set different in different pages when you log in.
And if you if you just change the session, the session token, it doesn't log you in it like flips out and tells and like alerts the authorities.
Hmm.
So I did that for like four days, five days.
I tried to get you spent four days trying to find a login CSRF.
I tried to like mimic that flow.
Oh, no.
And try to like set the right cookies and like do all the right stuff.
And I still can't even figure out the flow, to be honest, even after all that time.
Oh, my gosh.
So then I started looking at sub domains and I actually did like jhaddix's entire thing to get all of the, you know, and I spent like a week looking at all the sub domains.
And I found, thankfully, reflected XSS on a sub dome.
Sorry, I saw a post message, reflect this via post message on another sub domain.
Thank God.
And so then I used that to set the cookie for the main domain.
So you just document that cookie equals.
Sorry.
No, no, no.
I'm just trying to put it all in my head.
So we've got the graph here, right?
So, so you've got the post message XSS.
Yeah.
That's on the sub domain.
So, and because of that, you can set cookies for the whole domain.
Right?
So then you, you use the document, use the post message XSS to document.cookie and set these cookies to the specific path of the self XSS.
That's right.
And then, so you essentially use it as a login CSRF for the main domain.
I used it as a login.
Actually, I still didn't really even understand which cookies were which.
So I just, I took all my cookies.
Oh my gosh.
Like 12 to 13 cookies.
And I just set all of them to my, to my, my attacker cookies.
And I got, it's finally worked after like the 12th cookie.
And then I, I set it to a specific path to the path of the self XSS.
And then I redirected the, the second window to that.
So then it set the local storage parameter.
And then I redirected it again back to the main site where I then had the XSS.
Wow.
Okay.
So we do have a graph on the screen for those of you that are, that are watching on YouTube.
Um, so the, the whole flow is this, let me, let me repeat it back to you, dude.
I also just have to say crazy props for the amount of like.
Endurance and like, I don't know what's, what's the word gum on is the word in Japanese, but like, you just stuck to it.
Stuck to witness that you did to get this.
Um, so first step post message XSS on the sub domain.
Then you use the, you get the XSS.
Then you use the Matan bear trick to have yourself logged in as the attacker only on that specific endpoint.
That allows you to, uh, trigger the self XSS.
Then now you, you redirect to that endpoint, trigger the stored self XSS.
Then that, uh, stored XSS changes the local storage entry that was, would create the persistent XSS on every single page.
And then now wherever the victim clicks and they would never click on your listing anyway, cause it's your, it's that the URL is your specific listing.
So it's essentially as if they were not logged in at all to the attacker's account, right?
They're just logged into their own.
That's correct.
But the local storage is still shared.
And so it pops XSS on every single page on the victim's account.
That is correct.
That that's the, it's, it was the greatest moment of my life.
I mean, I have kids, but I think it was the greatest moment of my life.
Oh my God, dude.
What a, what an amazing, what an amazing find.
And, um, yeah, so you built out a little lab for this as well.
So thanks for that.
Um, we're actually going to drop that lab and a little explanation of the lab, um, to the critical thinkers tier on discord.
So, um, we'll go ahead and cut it here.
And, uh, if you're interested in seeing the rest of it, make sure you check out the critical thinkers, uh, on discord.
Thanks so much.